Now, so far, we've only worked with the decision variant of vertex cover.
So, what about the optimization problem? Actually, that's not that difficult.
We just run through all values of K. So we will first start off assuming K=1.
Then our algorithm requires O(2.4¹n³), then we'll increase K=2, algorithm requires o(2.4²n³).
So each time we're solving the decision problem here,
and we increase K even further to K=3 and so on and so on and so on.
Until we hit some value k’ which is the size of the smallest vertex cover of the input graph.
Of course, we don't know what that size will be in advanced?
But once we have increased K enough, solving the decision variant will give us the answer, yes.
Now, how much running time is this in total?
Well, you need to know a bit of discrete mathematics for this,
but running time O(2.4¹+2.4²+)...(2.4^k')n²).
Now if you have a discrete math course and remember what you learned there,
you will recognize this part here as a geometric series
and this evaluates to (2.4^k'⁻¹-1/2.4-1) which is the same as 0(2.4^k'),
and k' is the size of the smallest vertex cover n³. We forgot the n³ here which is right here.
And this is amazing because now it means that not only the decision variant of vertex cover
can be solved in (2.4^k' n³) time, but it means that the optimization variant of vertex cover
can also be solved in O(2.4^k'n³ )time,
where k is the minimum size of a vertex cover for the input graph.
And this again emphasizes the fact, small vertex covers are easy to find
even if we don't know that a graph has a small vertex cover as long as it is small,
it will be easy to find and for any fixed k, so either in the decision variant, we fixed k
or we say we look at all graphs that say have a vertex cover of size 10 or 20 or 30,
we can solve this NP complete problem in polynomial time.
And this is a concept known as Fixed Parameter Tractability.
Well, that means is that as long as the parameter that measures the hardness
and in this case, it's the size of a vertex cover for your graph,
as long as that parameter is small or fixed, then you can solve that problem in polynomial time
and that is what this here says, so as long as the parameter is fixed,
the problem is tractable, if the parameter is not fixed, so for example,
there's a function of n, then the problem is not tractable.
And this of course is a super neat technique for solving vertex cover
and actually 2.4^k is actually a very bad exponent here.
We only did that because of what's easier to explain the problem that way.
The currently best algorithms have an exponential factor of about 1.3^k.
Actually, a current state of the art is that you can solve vertex cover in
1.3^k times some polynomial time.
Now, the polynomial here that depends on certain analysis factors and so on
but the important thing here is to see, first of all, vertex cover is fixed parameter tractable
and second of all, the base of the exponent is actually really good.
It's only 1.3^k.